our Academy president will now return to
present special Awards voted by the
Board of Governors mr. Herschel each
year our governors are privileged to
confer special honor upon achievements
which they feel the self particular
recognition
this year we have voted the following
special awards to even handled for the
outstanding juvenile performance of 1948
in the search
mr. Fred cinnamon builder acceptor now
to seek common master showman who raised
the standard of exhibition of motion
pictures
ladies and gentlemen I don't know what
to say only that when I had my 35th
birthday I look back and say they didn't
forget me
two adults uka a man who has been called
the father of the feature film in
America for his services to the industry
over a period of 40 years
mr. routine so God will accept their
worthless father
on behalf of my father I'm awfully sorry
that he isn't here - so I'll join this
wonderful ization of this fine
expression from you all and I'll tell
him how wonderful this was he spoke to
me this evening and tell me that this
would have been a high spotless career -
Walter Winchell for distinguished
service to the industry in adding to its
moral stature in the world community by
this production of the picture Joan of
Arc
all of May I say this I have no doubt
but the citation on this award that
you're just a seat expressed the
sentiments of the best picture going
audience which have already seen your
great picture and will in time to come
see it
Thank You Jean the ladies and gentlemen
notwithstanding the citation I cannot
accept that except in the names of my
partners miss Ingrid Bergman and mr.
Victor Fleming who made this great
picture possible thank you and now
ladies and gentlemen the Irving G
Thalberg award as you remember we
skipped it last year and have skated
several years the thought world award is
given to the most consistent high
quality of production achievement by an
individual producer based on a picture
or pictures which he has personally
produced this year they are what goes to
j-wahl
mr. Ward I'm sure that they were born in
the industry but we have to see this
important award for Senator you for the
many outstanding pictures that you have
produced mr. Herschel there's very
little I can say except I do hope I can
put back into the picture business half
as much as you'd give me tonight thank
you very much
Thank You Jean Hersholt